petit
[Musique]
avec quatre invités bonjour à tous vous
pouvez prendre vos micros et je vais
vous présenter tout de suite les abello
sébastien carassou thaïs goldberg et
nihel bekhti bienvenus alors pourquoi
vous êtes là vous à oui c'est vrai parce
qu'il ya quelque chose qui s'appelle
youtube et qui marche super bien pour
parler de sciences
aujourd'hui alors on va faire les
présentations par ordre d'arrivée sur
youtube alors on va commencer par
l'ancien sébastien carassou youtuber et
docteur en astrophysique pour la chaîne
sense of wonder depuis trois ans très
ancien mais oui très anciens les abello
docteur en géophysique qui a bifurqué
vers youtube il ya exactement un an
presque un an c'est ça ouais et les deux
petites novices alors vous vous êtes
chercheur à la base pour le cea et vous
avez gagné un concours en interne qui
s'appelle science tum de vulgarisation
de vos travaux on reviendra vers vous a
eu comme je l'aï dit je vais commencer
par toi sébastien l'incarnation et les
anciens savaient pour parler toi le
mieux c'est de montrer un extrait de ce
que tu fais sur youtube on regarde tout
de suite un extrait de sense of wonder
voilà
si je vous demande d'imaginer un trou
noir là maintenant il ya de grandes
chances pour que l'image qui vous vient
en tête soit celle là si vous avez la
malchance des dans la direction d'un g2
sursauts gamma à moins de dix mille
années lumière d'ici et ça va commencer
à chauffer pour vous un littéralement un
sursaut vous pouvez voir ça comme
l'équivalent du rayon de l'étoile de la
mort pour le coup c'est littéralement
l'étoile de la mort oui jarjat va
bientôt rentrer chez toi alors sébastien
carassou la particularité de cette
chaîne c'est que tu l'a lancé avant de
passer ta thèse en astrophysique ne me
trompe pas alors c'était au tout début
de ma thèse en fait alors en commençant
c'est à dire en commençant lors des
premiers mois de ma thèse je me suis dit
je m'ennuie non mais franchement ce
n'était pas assez de choses à faire
je me suis dit je vais prendre un truc
qu'on le croyait youtube et ont fait une
thèse en même temps on réussit les deux
bien sûr oui bah la thèse est soutenue
tu as donné la thèse est soutenue
docteur officiellement aujourd'hui tu te
sens youtuber médiateur chercheurs les
trois son passeur de science voilà je
n'aime pas me limiter à un format
il estime que youtube c'est le format
qui marche le mieux mais c'est pas le
seul que je enfin que je vise en tout
cas j'essaie de garder une majorité des
médias possibles pour exemple le cabaret
des sciences aujourd'hui sur rmc pas mal
et la chaîne à cent mille abonnés ça
marche bien tout à fait mais il ya quand
même un imaginaire au tour de youtube
c'est à dire que on s'imagine que les
gens vivent dans beaucoup de vidéos
gagnent leur vie si on se remet au
niveau des sciences et en france les
gens qui vivent de youtube et qui parle
de science ils se comptent sur les
doigts d'un doigt ou deux en fait
exactement exactement moi moi je peux
vivre grâce à je vais vous dire mon
secret tout de suite mon secret c'est le
chômage
et oui et oui ça fait vivre beaucoup de
vidéastes aujourd'hui et ça permet
d'avoir une certaine liberté créative
pendant au moins un moment moi ça c'est
deux ans donc
pendant deux ans je peux me consacrer
entièrement à ma chaîne escales mais une
liberté qui est pas négligeable
alors qui sont les youtuber scientifique
c'est quoi leur profil qui sont ceux
qu'on regarde beaucoup parler de
sciences sur internet alors il ya tania
louis du café des sciences qui a fait 1
un article oui une étude sur les
vidéastes du café des sciences donc une
association vulgarisateur qui compte
aujourd'hui plus de 200 dugarry thater
sur tous les formats dont 80 90 vidéaste
et sur ces 80 90 vidéaste ce qui est fou
c'est que le 70% 72% des profils sont
des profils scientifiques donc c'est des
gens qui vulgarise dans leur domaine de
compétence donc si on en parle sur
youtube c'est qu'on aime ça déjà déjà il
ya une grosse passion derrière il ya une
volonté de diffuser les connaissances et
une volonté qui peut coûter cher en
termes de temps et d'investissement
personnel c'est pas négligeable de faire
part en fait youtube c'est plusieurs
métiers à la fois c'est le métier
d'auteur c'est le métier de réalisateur
de monteur de community manager et c'est
plein de plein de métiers que
généralement les gens segmente dans le
monde professionnel de l'audiovisuel et
qu'on est obligé de faire tout seul
enfin moi je suis pas tout seul jeu à
deux chances sur ce projet donc j'ai la
chance d'avoir quelqu'un qui m'aide à
faire ça et ils tiennent le dolley mais
je sais que beaucoup de beaucoup de mes
amis sont tous seuls à tout faire et
c'est pas facile
les abbés l'eau je vais me tourner vers
vous maintenant alors vous ça s'est fait
un peu dans l'autre sens vous êtes
géophysicienne pour le cnrs passionnés
du gard isation et l'année dernière vous
lancer sur youtube avec quelques
camarades une chaîne sponsorisé par le
cnrs qui s'appelle est de science alors
quelle était l'idée c'est de suivre le
mouvement un petit peu pour le pour le
cnrs et pour ce que vous avez fait vous
alors moi je suis pas j'ai enfin je suis
j'ai fait une thèse de géophysique après
je me suis réorientée vers
vers la vulgarisation scientifique ce
que j'avais déjà commencé en thèse à
l'époque j'avais pas encore j'aimerais
ans et sur youtube et l'idée ça a été il
ya un an c'est le cnrs qui qui a eu
envie de ça on a lancé un projet en fait
pour faire des créations youtube est
vraiment un format qui s'intégrait un
peu dans l'écosystème de la
vulgarisation qui existent déjà du coup
bas depuis quatre ans bientôt et bien
voilà l'idée c'était ça on est 3 du coup
nous aussi
motif de la chance d'avoir des gens qui
m'aident pour la réalisation le montage
la re lecture des textes etc
on va regarder un extrait de ce que
propose la chaîne zeste de science
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour à tous si je vous demande de
dessiner des branches d'arbres vous avez
sûrement faire quelque chose qui
ressemble à ce que fait mon petit frère
que se passe-t-il dans la tête de ces
petites abeilles paisible ouvrière pour
qu'ils se transforment aussi vite en des
kamikazes déterminés prêts à mourir pour
défendre leurs ruches
alors à chaque fois ce sont des vidéos
qui reprennent les travaux de chercheurs
du cnrs c'est un petit peu le bris lycée
le brief c'est ça c'est on a on regarde
un peu les actualités de laboratoire et
puis on prend on s'attache à un résultat
où une une recherche un projet qui sur
lesquels il ya des images puisque en
fait on se base aussi pas mal sur les
images qui sont produites dans les
laboratoires les chercheurs
et voilà à l'aide de ces images et
on va écrire un petit texte pour
vulgariser et décrypter un peu la
recherche qui est derrière alors c'est
quoi le ton et youtube je sais qu'un a
pas qu'un mais c'est quoi les grandes
lignes de ce que vous avez voulu faire
en arrivant avec des travaux de
l'institut commun cnrs pour les
vulgariser sur youtube alors déjà ça a
été de rendre assez accessible donc
c'est le principe de la vulgarisation et
puis évidemment rendre ça un peu marrant
parce que pour vous pour s'y attacher un
peu nous on a choisi un format plus
court que seb donc on s'est limité un
peu un format assez court et oui voilà
ça en gros c'est resté scientifique est
validée travail avec le chercheur pour
l'écriture et puis mais derrière rendra
accessibles en utilisant comme l'air que
tout le monde comprend des belles
métaphores des belles images et puis
voilà un peu d'humour thaïs otsberg et
bignell bekhti est ce que vous regardez
les chaînes de sébastien ou aux as tu
dossier savent ce que vous connaissiez
je trouve ça très intéressant comme
initiative
bon moi je suis novice dans le domaine
de la médiation scientifique donc mais
c'est un
impôts un projet que je trouve très
intéressant de la part d'un organisme
vraiment puisque du coup c'est vraiment
organisé par le cnrs 16 ans je trouve ça
important quand on travaille dans un
organisme de recherche public de rendre
accessible au grand public les résultats
des travaux qui financent finalement
donc c'est un beau projet et bien sûr
même en tant qu'individu mais super
eagle bekhti est ce que c'est le fait de
regarder des vidéos sur youtube qui vous
a donné envie de répondre à ce concours
du cio a science tube de vulgarisation
ou vous mettiez un doux en scène dans
des vidéos
c'était une partie c'était une
motivation parmi d'autres oui en effet
donc déjà ça m'avait beaucoup aidé en
fait à à penser aux idées que je pouvais
mettre dans ma vidéo montage etc
ça m'avait beaucoup inspiré en effet est
aussi en fait j'ai pensé plus à la
vulgarisation et le partage de mon
projet de thèse parce que je suis dr
entend actuellement
et comme j'avais eu souvent en fait la
question sur quel était mon projet et
j'ai remarqué en fait que mon nom mon
retour en fait été adaptée à chaque fois
aux types d'interlocuteurs qui me posait
la question et je me suis dit pourquoi
pas le vulgariser atteindre un maximum
de public et partager tout simplement
mon projet alors on va regarder un
extrait de la vidéo qui vous a fait
gagner ce concours sciences tube vous
avez sûrement dû déjà emparée de
certains aliments à éviter envers de
grossesse certains médicaments des
conseillers pour les femmes enceintes
en effet la faim durant la grossesse est
extrêmement sensible je maintiens
fadaises très spécifiquement en
développement d'allergies alimentaires
chez l'enfant est très précisément
durant les cinq premières années de vie
en comparant les mécanismes et allergies
ou dans l'allergie qu on va pouvoir
identifier des biomarqueurs précoces
d'allergies alimentaires remonter à leur
sauce d'apparition et pouvoir mettre en
place des stratégies préventives pour
plus tard alors tu as is hot berges vous
avez terminé deuxième et apparemment
c'est pas à regarder youtube qui vous a
donné envie de participer vous que vous
n'êtes pas trop consommatrices à ce que
vous avez dit non c'est vrai j'ai
participé à ma thèse en 180 secondes ya
les ans donc ça a été ma première
occasion de
de faire de la médiation scientifique et
quand j'ai vu l'appel à candidatures
pour ce concours
je me suis dit que j'avais déjà le
speech donc j'avais plus qu'à mettre en
images la flamme je me rendais pas
compte que ça prendrait alors dans le
temps sébastien l'a dit il ya du travail
on va regarder ce que vous avez fait
vous aussi bon super championnat mois
s'appelle penicillium il à sauver les
millions vit grâce à sa production aux
pénicillines vous savez le tout premier
antibiotique
l'objectif de mes recherches c'est de
comprendre ce qui rend penicillium si
nocif et de potentialiser le meilleur de
lui-même viennent à présent les
questions cruciales quelles sont les
fonctions de ces molécules desquels
devons nous méfier mais dès qu'elle
pourrions-nous nous servir et oui les
antibiotiques c'est peut-être pas
automatique mais justement ça nous
aiderait pas mal d'en trouver des
nouveaux alors je vais vous poser la
question à tous les cas peut-être à
sébastien pour répondre en premier
ça fait 13 ans que youtube existe ça
fait sept ans qu'on y parle de science
quatre ans que ça cartonne en france
est-ce que ça va durer est ce que tu
penses qu'il ya un modèle qui va émerger
et on va vraiment avoir une
spécialisation des professionnels alors
c'est super intéressant parce qu'on me
demande de prévoir l'avenir et
généralement quand on demande à des
experts ou des gens de prévoir l'avenir
cinq ans ou dix ans plus tard on se rend
compte qu'ils avaient tort donc je vais
pas me risquer à faire des prédictions
sur ce qui va marcher ou ce qui va pas
marcher
par contre ce qu'on est en train de voir
émerger c'est un écosystème de type 2
deux formats de narration et qui
fonctionne très très bien parce que
c'est très complémentaire n'y a pas une
espèce de disons qu'il ya une une
pression de sélection dans dans le type
de format qu'est ce qui va marcher le
mieux qu est-ce qui est qu'est ce qui va
devenir virale et c'est sur le moment
mais sur le long terme il ya une
diversité des formats qui secret et ce
qui est intéressant c'est ça commence de
plus en plus à ceux à se
professionnaliser comme comme tu disais
il ya les institutions iliad qui
commence à venir nous voir pour faire
des partenariats il ya par exemple des
xes de sciences j'avais fait une vidéo
avec le avec le cnrs était très bien il
ya des boîtes de prod qui commence à
faire des des formes à nouveau avec une
image plus clean et donc qui commence à
vraiment investir ce bestiaire youtube
parfois à pertes donc ça c'est vraiment
super important dont il ya un pari sur
l'avenir qui est fait et donc voilà il
ya toute une diversité qui arrive je
sais pas si ça va continuer longtemps on
n'a pas eu à changer son algorithme
pourrait dire il ya une inconnue soit
c'est youtube
c'est à dire que tout est basé sur une
plateforme unique exactement
il n'est pas fait forcément pour vous ll
est la plateforme youtube n'est pas fait
pour les créateurs allez faites pour les
annonceurs et les annonceurs de
définissent un petit peu les grandes
lignes de ce que va devenir youtube plus
tard et on sait pas ce que va devenir
youtube plus tard dans trois mois
peut-être que ce qui marche pas c'est
des vidéos de 3 secondes et moi fernet
d'irisation en 3 secondes
c'est très sexy c'est donc voilà il faut
s'adapter
le format nous fameux la plateforme nous
oblige à nous adapter et mais en même
temps ça pousse à la créativité aussi ça
nous force à nous pousse à créer de
nouveaux formats créer de nouvelles
formes de narration qui peuvent toucher
des gens de manière très différente eh
oui et les gens et surtout les jeunes
parce que les abbés l'eau c'est le moyen
aussi d'aller s'adresser aux jeunes et
de leur parler de science aujourd'hui
c'est youtube
oui en fait youtube c'est presque une
porte d'entrée et ce que disait sème
tout à l'heure c'est vrai les
les youtuber en fait ont plusieurs
cordes à leur arc est et en général
c'est des vulgarisateurs en vidéo ils
font aussi des livres des conférences et
et pour nous en tout cas pour le cnrs
c'est aussi une porte d'entrée vers
d'autres contenus plus long plus
détaillé vers et tout ça permet de
toucher un public qu'on toucherait pas
autrement
en fait on a beaucoup de mal à toucher
le public plus jeune et c'est vrai que
youtube nous offre cette possibilité là
tous les deux que quel est l'âge moyen
de vos abonnés sur vos chaises
alors moi je sais que je touche
majoritairement des 18-35 ans 91 %
d'hommes je tiens à préciser c'est
déprimant
ah oui quand même c'est vrai j'ai un peu
non non on est à 70 % d'hommes tyson
bergé niel mais qu'est ce que vous allez
continuer ce que vous allez lancer une
chaîne rejoindre un collectif de
vidéastes
est ce que ça vous a donné envie c'est
beaucoup de travail
c'est très très chronophage
donc avec plaisir hein j'adore
transmettre des connaissances et
sensibiliser le maximum de personnes au
monde qui nous entoure et mais est ce
que le temps le permettra
le cea va continuer à produire comme le
cnrs des contenus vidéo sur youtube
après ce concours peut-être qu'il y aura
une deuxième édition de science yeux
donc ça restera sûrement un concours par
une chaîne où quelques hommes êtes aussi
alors on va reparler un peu de zeste de
sciences les thèmes que vous abordez
c'est le cnrs est très large donc c'est
toute la science
oui c'est plein de plein de sujets
différents et en fait c'est l'actualité
des laboratoires qui soit purement
ceineray souder des unités mixtes avec
d'autres universités et l'idée c'est
vraiment de toucher plein de thématiques
différentes pour intéresser
plein de gens différents et et puis
voilà pour pas se restreindre
on a c'est vrai plus de facilité à
traiter des sujets très
et sciences dures et avaient je mets
tous les guillemets qu'il faut autour de
cette appellation
mais c'est vrai qu'on a plus d' images
qui proviennent de laboratoires en
physique chimie biologie et puis on a
quelques quelques
épisode sur des sciences humaines et
sociales et puis des mathématiques
voilà comment vous travaillez les vidéos
vous fait valider par les chercheurs qui
ont produit les résultats
oui en fait on donc je vais écrire un
premier enfin d'abord en contact le
chercheur il faut savoir s'il a envie
qu'on parle de sa recherche de cette
façon là donc j'ai souvent non non non
jamais ça ne m'est jamais arrivé mais on
sait pas on pourrait tomber sur
quelqu'un qui n'aime pas cette façon de
briser
donc à partir de l'article
à partir de s'il existe un contenu en
français ou pour la presse on va écrire
donc j'écris un premier brouillon et je
l'envoie aux chercheurs qui va me dire
si oui ou non il ya des erreurs
scientifiques donc l'idée étant vraiment
d'avoir une validation de chercheurs
derrière qui nous dit ok
scientifiquement le contenu est bon
après on se garde la liberté de faire
plein de blagues mais les chercheurs
sont aussi nos premiers spectateurs et
pour l'instant on suggère un peu des
blagues aussi non au front mais par
contre on a des commentaires
raoult peut-être celle là bof
alors c'est bastia carassou je vais pas
vous demander comment vous validez vos
résultats puisque c'est des résultats
vous êtes chercheur donc c'est un peu un
peu facile de dire vous êtes votre
propre juge a alors ce serait le cas si
j'avais aucune conscience
professionnelle mais en fait j'ai emmené
la une du coup je fais toujours relire
mes textes
que ce soit par des par des experts du
domaine ou par des gens qui n'ont jamais
touché à l'astrophysique et s'assure sa
super intéressant parce que ça nous
donne déjà par mois ça m'évite de dire
des bêtises avec son retour d'experts là
et j'en ai dit d'accord j'ai beau être
expert en astrophysique je suis pas
expert dans tout l'astrophysique j'avais
écrit un script sur les éruptions
solaires par exemple pour une chaîne ça
fait string theory et sur les
résolutions sur l'air j'avais dit
énormément de bêtises
alex est donc heureusement que j'avais
fait relire avant et donc avec une
chercheuse mis au janvier qu'il y avait
acceptés gratuitement de me relire
fantastique
elle a corrigé toutes mes erreurs et du
coup je pourrais dire les choses de
manière plus plus fiables après j'aime
bien avoir une espèce de public test
avant la sortie de la vidéo pour savoir
si est ce que les gens me comprennent
est ce que certaines blagues passe est
ce que certaines manières de raconter
les histoires sont attrayantes et c'est
toujours un empiriques ont ce qu'on sait
jamais si ça va marcher à l'avance ou
pas et surtout que le sense of wonder
c'est vraiment un une plate forme
d'expérimentation pour moi j'essaie de
devises et des nouvelles formes de
narration à chaque fois et voilà parce
que ça me fait ça me fait progresser
aussi et donc on va les guider c'est
vraiment d'avoir c'est ce double retour
là et donc avec le café des sciences par
exemple on a une sélection de groupes
facebook on peut se faire relire les
strips mon art par des pairs donc par
des gens qui font aussi des vidéos de
vulgarisation donc on appelle ça le pire
vidéo wii en relation au pire reviewing
delà de la méthode scientifique c'est
super passionnant parce que ça me permet
vraiment d'avoir à la fois le recul d'
expertise technique et de comment est-ce
que le message il est perçu mais alors
là on ouvre une porte quand même pour
vous le problème se pose pas quand même
parce qu on a un organisme de recherche
derrière est de science sébastien tu
nous expliquer comment tu fais tes
vidéos ça a l'air sérieux mais sur
youtube on peut tout le monde peut
poster une vidéo
labellisé science avoir du succès et
pourtant dire beaucoup de bêtises
oui ça arrive que comment quand on
arrive sur la plate forme et qu'on veut
consommer on s'assure que ce qu'on
regarde et véridique et que c'est des
vrais les travaux qu'ils sont publiés
alors là
là en tant que spectateurs oui quand on
arrive sur une chaîne youtube et
quelqu'un d'ouvert de science moi la
première chose que je fais alors
première chose c'est la deuxième chose
que je fais après avoir regardé la vidéo
c'est de regarder la description pour
voir si la personne mais les sources de
ce qu'elle dit il ya un souci de
transparence et de responsabilité qu'un
vidéaste qui fait de la bonne
vulgarisation devrait avoir et l'idée
c'est déjà de rendre à césar ce qui est
à césar
il n'y a pas le losc ce que vous
apprenez et ça vient pas du saint-esprit
ça vient d'eux d'articles scientifiques
ou de bouquins que vous avez lu donc le
fait de mettre ses références c'est
toujours important de travaux que vous
avez menées ou des travaux et puis et
puis ça permet aussi d'avoir une
connexion avec le public d'avoir un lien
de confiance avec le public je dire
c'est si les gens veulent aller plus
loin qu'une vidéo de 10 minutes sur un
sujet ils peuvent aller voir les sources
directes ou des mois je poste aussi des
articles de blogs de chercheurs parfois
kiwi enfin ces articles mettent des des
références plus plus complexes comme ça
ils peuvent avoir une espèce de disques
et d'escaliers vers une vulgarisation
qui est de moins en moins vulgariser et
qui peut étancher leur soif de culture
bon merci pour ce conseil on va essayer
de les retenir
[Musique]